does that red box come with it uh yeah
you gotta make sure they know you got
your papers these ain't the fake one to
pay these de Road deals with the
booklets which pop in his right ear is
dis GQ ten essentials definitely the
joined retro was like one of my favorite
sneakers but I mean this was just one of
the plenty retro ones that I have in my
collection but you could kind of work
with anything Jean sweats it's everyday
sneaker I always got a pair was them so
they ran twice which is what I had in
Atlanta I can't remember my first pair I
was I just know growing up it was like
one of my favorite sneakers I know my
first pair of Jordans period was the
Lebanese to bridge I had a pair of the
original nervous but I don't know when I
got older the waters became my favorite
this is free Aventis everybody he meets
me actually what I wear this is me
revealing what I wear so if you want
your boyfriend smile like me go get some
pre for Christmas I started wearing
Creed recently pride about two years ago
it smell like it ever since
it smell like a doctor I like a lawyer
it's like a it's like a it's not a
specific smell you could say is just
like like when you around somebody you
smell them they smell like money like
that well that's well doctors I think
they smother yeah very expensive this is
my caveat a pro sitting Cuban
the diners pop out of the Cubans not
just a regular diamonds in the Cuban
this gold to push the divers out making
pop
don't worry all the time but it's
definitely so mine I pop out when I just
want to have something simple but still
shine at the same time and this is my
protect Philippe it's a very nice watch
one of my first buzz downs ever bought
stainless steel but it has diamonds in
it is simple less is more
the chattin is worth about $60,000 and
this watch is worth one hundred thousand
jewelry isn't a necessity but sometimes
it it could bring out my fashion
sometimes if I'm wearing very dark
clothes like darker colored black
anything like that
I put white jury on top it looked crazy
because it's like the kind of tries to
the diamonds in dark clothes some
colleges do it for fashion I already do
it the stunts I've gotta start Hardy
eight shades I have a couple different
styles Kayne these were actually a gift
for my good friend slow he gave me these
Cartier's one night was at July's in New
York complimented on Mona's glasses cuz
I seen that they were Cartier and gave
me these Cartier's I got more Louboutin
glasses and I do Cartier but Louis
Vuitton I'd like more it's like a
fashion like glasses like you wear those
when you're going out and cameras and
stuff going around but my if you got
cardio you could just wear those like
anything every day and uh you know
Cartier this is the original right ear
it's piece is the first chain I ever
bought ever my life I got this like
right after I dropped feed the streets
the first mixtape it's not like
something I wear or nothing it's just
it's just a chain I keep cuz like it
just reminds me of the beginning it's
probably the only thing that has stood
with my name Whitney the more I read
successive the more I go up in life I
felt like this chain is and I was more
and every time I look at this changes
your minds know where I've been
the mother mentality I had to get to
where I'm at so every day I look at this
and keep that same you know driving
motivation you know it's just a process
you got a treasure process those new
things going on every day you gotta just
adapt to it continue to be great I
always have water around me everywhere I
go
this is essentia some overachieving
vegetable essentia is a water that I got
more into drinking after going to the
studio a lot I had different waters on a
chart you know I just like to sit remove
the stitches it's essential I always
drink your water these are smaller
pineapple chunks they not fold because I
was eating them my mom had me eat these
mandalas younger so I just liked them a
lot they like my favorite fruit I kind
of charge drink drink a lot of water eat
more fruit and stuff like that even
though it's it's a lot of as their knees
it's not really good to overeat them but
it's a good food I like pie that was
definitely one of my essential fruits
every day
my next everyday search I couldn't bring
it in it's a hellcat I just recently got
to live 20/20 girl cat with the wide
body kit that's my everyday car there's
a car that they might see every day but
they get up like a cool car to just have
all the time blacked it all around still
about casinos over 70 north bar - oh no
no - there's a car that I started with
so I just always wanted to keep one and
this year just so I'm gonna be a good
year 2020 I don't like going to big I
like to just keep it modest I pull out
the cars when it's time you know watch
out for it okay every day
first beast fenelby chopstick a lot of
different chopsticks I don't really like
them because I they taste I don't know
how to make your lips feel after but
birds bees keep my lips like cool
scissors vanilla bean they're like taste
like it's like a sweet it's cool
it ain't like no weird then going on so
I like this chesty I'm gonna just say
not gonna go to in detail what I do with
these but I feel like Rocco's the king
size is a brand that I could trust it is
your choice it's a healthier choice
it's a lighter big blue this one of the
Centers just to have a lighter on me you
know never know what you might have to
use I like my lighters to be blue and
small like fit in the pocket
they always blue I love a lot of camel
and not always but they're always small
like this cuz I lose a lot of lighters
so I just try to keep it in my pocket as
much as I can so if I if I got a like a
big lighter I won't put it back in my
pocket put it on the table itself but if
it's smart I could just slide it right
back in my pocket so I've been keeping
up with this one for like four days
this is probably my longest record I was
like every day but it's just cool album
when you live
American Express I've been a member
since this year so I'm proud had to put
the tape on it because the scammers is
real you know I'm ducking all the
scammers I used to hear jay-z talk about
American Express a lot so once I got my
little card I thought I was something I
feel like this is essential for me
because everywhere I go I might need to
make a transaction what I got to do and
it's getting to a point where I don't
like to carry around that much money
because it could be a liability I just
needed to turn up the limits on my cars
and America
expresses is one of the ones I got a big
lemon on it so gotta keep the American
Express what's good GQ I appreciate
y'all for letting me share my essentials
my daily essentials the errbody to go
listen to the album please II seem to be
antisocial out everywhere right now